[Music]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream
101 am i correct about that number yes
after a brief
reprieve we're back into palindrome
territory
it is a palindrome i had not even
noticed that do you know how i
calculated that it was live stream 101
no i did not i worked forward from last
week's having been 100 and it was a
straightforward back of the envelope
kind of calculation yeah here at
darkhorse we show our work
on envelopes if we have them available
where are they
this is awkward yeah i think so
all right all right this week we are
going to talk a little bit more about
consensus as we did last week uh and and
illness and discovery and i'll just
leave that sort of vague for now
uh we are going to discuss um a little
bit about some new research from some
obstetricians not the research by
obstetricians but about obstetricians
we have a article from the washington
post that we want to say a few words
about you've got something in the works
that you have not told me about yet
you're making a rabbit face at me you'd
kill it if i told you ahead of time yep
and we're going to finish up with a 1948
essay from c.s lewis that a fan sent me
yesterday and it's extraordinary it's
short it's extraordinary and it is
very much of the moment despite having
been written uh many many decades ago
so first off though let's do let's do
logistics and pay the rent uh book is
now in stock a hundred gatherers guide
to the 21st century was in stock last
week it's still in stock so please if
you want it
go get it it should be available
everywhere at this point
if you
read it and liked it please consider
giving a review on any of a number of
places we have been hearing that some
reviews have been disappearing we don't
know why
but if you think that might have
happened to yours please consider going
back in and
and writing it again or get the audio
book or take it out of a library and
read it either you know any of those
things um
okay if you're watching on youtube
consider switching to odyssey that's
where the live chat is happening
ask questions in the q a that will be
happening after this at
darkhorseammissions.com consider joining
our patreons
right now through midday sunday pacific
the 40-hour 48-hour question asking
period is open at my patreon for the
once monthly private q a to our q a that
we do on the last sunday of every month
at 11 a.m pacific
you can ask those questions right now
come consider joining me at natural
selections all the written
all the essays the tuesday posts are
free this week i was writing about
phenotypic plasticity in in a hypothesis
about maple trees
and some
established research in tree frogs for
instance and this upcoming week
i'm going to be writing about vitamin d
deficiency
and its implications for covid so that's
in the upcoming natural selections again
uh free
free on tuesdays and without further ado
we've got three sponsors for this week
so let's
do it let's do it
uh let me first say we are very
grateful to our sponsors because this is
a very difficult moment and it would
seem like um
good people trying to do the right thing
uh on video is the kind of thing that
would be very easy to support but
it turns out you need courageous
sponsors and we appreciate you so thanks
all right let's start with relief band
our first sponsor is relief band a
product that can help with nausea first
though a little about nausea under
ancient circumstances some modern ones
nausea was generally useful it was a
signal that something was off that you
had eaten something you shouldn't have
or wear something emanating a bad smell
itself a signal that you should not get
near it in modernity we still need to
track our bodily sensitivities we should
not always choose to simply
erase discomfort like nausea whenever we
feel it that said some of modernity
creates nausea that does no good at all
travel sickness for instance can be
agonizing and relief would be lovely
enter relief band relief band is an
anti-nausea wristband that has been
clinically proven to relieve and prevent
nausea associated with motion sickness
anxiety migraines chemotherapy and more
relief band is 100 drug free and can be
used for as long as you need it
developed over 20 years ago
it is the only over-the-counter wearable
device that has been used in hospitals
and oncology clinics to treat nausea and
vomiting
we do not suffer from nausea but we
asked a friend who does to try it out
here is her testimonial
i used to have nausea on a nearly daily
basis from both anxiety and the need to
take regular medication relief band
relieves my nausea in less than three
minutes without the side effects i was
experiencing from anti-nausea medication
it has been it has entirely changed my
life for the better
as you're getting ready for a road trip
or a boat trip or expect actually we
should also say space travel undoubtedly
that should be added to the list um
and expect nausea for other or expect
nausea for other reasons consider relief
band which has an exclusive offer
for dark horse listeners go to
reliefband.com and use the promo code
darkhorse with 1h to receive 20 percent
off plus free shipping and no questions
asked 30-day money-back guarantee policy
so head to relief band
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d
dot com and use the promo code darkhorse
to get 20 off plus free shipping
all right our second two sponsors are
similar yet distinct enough that we
really we really like both of them
they're four sigmatic and mudwater both
of which we've brought to you before
four sigmatic is a wellness company
known for its delicious mushroom coffee
as well as protein powders that contain
mushrooms that sounds weird kind of
off-putting i was skeptical as i've said
here before but i've been drinking their
mushroom coffee most mornings and it's
really quite good
four sigmatics mushroom coffee contains
organic fair trades single origin
arabica coffee with both lion's mane and
chicago mushrooms
forcing maddie's ground mushroom coffee
with lion's mane adds a little something
some crispness and focus it's delicious
just like your favorite coffee dark and
nutty and wonderful
all four sigmatic products are organic
vegan and gluten-free and every batch is
third-party lab tested to ensure its
purity and safety and they have a 100
money-back guarantee love every sip or
get your money back so we have an
exclusive offer for with four sigmatic
on their best-selling mushroom coffee
for dark horse listeners get up to 40
off and free shipping on mushroom coffee
bundles to claim this deal go to
foursigmatic.com
darkhorse that's f o u r s i g m a t i c
dot com slash dark horse and fuel your
productivity and creativity with some
delicious mushroom coffee
our third sponsor for this week is water
m-u-d-w-t-r
mud water is a coffee alternative made
with mushrooms herbs and spices with
one-seventh the caffeine is a cup of
coffee you get energy without the
anxiety jitters or crash of coffee each
ingredient was added with intention it's
got cacao and chai
lion's mane cordyceps shaga and reishi
turmeric and cinnamon
and no coffee
i will say this i enjoy my coffee but i
don't need it that's intentional i've
spent time places where coffee was not
or might not be available so it's
important to me not to lose
functionality if i can't get it so i
wasn't sure that i needed or wanted this
product
but it's great it's actually great i'm a
sucker for chocolate and there's
definitely a hint of chocolate in it
same for their masala chai blend which
includes cinnamon turmeric ginger
cardamom black pepper nutmeg and cloves
and really with a lineup like that how
can you go wrong
excuse me i've also been adding it to
the occasional smoothie and it gives it
a gives almost any smoothie not i
wouldn't add it necessarily to a light
bright fruity smoothie but um
but many smoothies i've added it to are
quite delicious mud water is 100 usda
organic non-gmo gluten free vegan kosher
certified furthermore they donate a
percentage of revenue to maps the
multi-disciplinary association for
psychedelic studies and they work with
pachama which pays monthly to
reforestation efforts to ensure that we
have a net they have a net positive
carbon footprint so visit mudwater.com
darkhorse to support the show and use
darkhorse at checkout for five dollars
off that's m-u-d-w-t-r-dot-com
darkhorse use darkhorse at checkout for
five dollars
off that's our ads for the week
oh yeah all right um
maybe first maybe before we oh i still
don't have my book you're gonna hey zach
no no no um there's a book down on my
desk in my office downstairs the doofat
book we are working without a net today
she's she always goes missing she's lazy
she does not come in for work nope
um luckily zach does and he is he is
ambulatory and is going to get my book
he is ambulant that's right he's not a
slug he's a real live person bipedal
even nor cedar tree or maple tree right
um but okay before i wanted to talk
about the this this remarkable new book
that's just about to be out though uh i
did want to say something about it being
episode 101 which is evocative of room
101 in orwell's 1984. this is the room
it's been a while since i read 1984 and
uh because of that and because i prefer
hard copies of books i only have the
hard copy and so i i didn't i wasn't
able to search yes perfect thank you sir
um i wasn't able to search on the book
uh inside the book but uh
but google helped
uh the room 101 in 1984 contains a
person's worst nightmare or fear you
betray big brother and you find yourself
in room 101 what's in there whatever is
worse for you
o'brien who's a member of the party in
the book
describes room 1 room 101 thusly quote
you asked me once what was in room 101 i
told you that you knew the answer
already everyone knows it the thing that
is in room 101 is the worst thing in the
world the worst thing in the world
varies from individual to individual it
may be burial alive or death by fire or
by drowning or my impalement or 50 other
deaths
there are cases where it is some quite
trivial thing
not even fatal
oh i've got my
room 101. um i'm i'm not sure you want
to tell the world what's in your room
one 101 but uh if if you do go for it
feel like it's written all over me like
they could just read it so easily they
already know what i'm about to say uh
the door locks from the outside sure and
inside it's customer service that's all
that's in there is customer service for
everything right everything you need
right you have to go through the phone
tree well there is no getting through
the phone tree the whole point of it is
to prevent you from getting what you
need right and so it's just it's not
even like starvation it's like
starvation with the promise that if only
you can reason your way through the
phone tree there might be something to
eat at the other side you know locked in
a room with no windows with a phone tree
that is endless
no recourse
to logic to kindness to human decency
right it's that it's that
i i dare you i defy you to try to think
of something worse i think you're right
i mean lake of fire that's nothing yeah
that is borders a lake of fire i mean
come on you just you get used to it
right it doesn't promise you anything i
mean i feel like spoken as a guy who's
not actually endured a lake of fire but
how did i know i died maybe i just
didn't mention it
that's true yeah you've mentioned a lot
of stuff failed to mention other things
it's possible you just didn't mention it
forgot
[Music]
okay
that was surprising that was surprising
uh so i don't know if the people
watching or listening could hear that
our um awesome 17 year old son slash
producer just advised his father
brett weinstein to stop moving the mouse
uh which was somehow making itself
visible on the screen why we have that
power i don't know now we don't right
you've turned off the power i i think i
have disabled the mouse excellent
okay
um last week we talked
to
a fair bit about consensus
and enforced consensus and
you had a few a few phrases
that you introduced around consensus and
youtube's terms of service
yes i'm trying to remember the uh the
exact phrase we settled on for the title
of uh last week's episode it was maybe
our excellent producer will figure it
out for us yes that would be good yes
uh because you had used one in the show
and then we used a slightly different
one and in the title
uh but i said while we were talking
about it you know the idea was that
we are told
right now that you need to follow the
science because the science is settled
and you can tell because look at all of
the people who say one thing and look at
how nobody is saying anything else
and there are a lot of reasons not to
buy that particular line of reasoning as
we talked about last week but one thing
i kept saying was actually i know we're
going to come back to this idea of
consensus next week and it is
um in service of boy we have we have
sort of a mess here this week because
some things failed and i can't actually
get my computer in front of me um
let's see if i can make this work
yeah what was it
the demolition of descent that's it yeah
oh my god
um
so boy
tech problems all over the place
okay
there is a book coming out next week
called the deep places a memoir of
illness and discovery by ross duthap
we were sent an advanced copy and uh
it's it's excellent i recommend it it's
not available quite yet i think it's
coming out on tuesday
it's really quite surprising it is
nominally as i've just read the subtitle
as well as the title a memoir of illness
and discovery
uh do that fight do that is a new york
times colonist and this is a different
sort of book for him
he finds himself sick and not getting
better with symptoms that are extreme
but which no doctor is able to diagnose
he's referred to psychologists of course
even his family is wondering if it's in
his head
as do that says in the book
um in the first year or two as he's
hoping against hope for a treatment that
works and occasionally gets blips you
know
an hour or two maybe even a day or two
in which he's feeling better he says the
feeling better moments never held and i
kept falling back into the pain and dark
and anyone who's experienced either
chronic illness or uh deep physical
trauma that took a very long time to
heal or is not completely healing will
recognize that
that sense of falling back into the pain
and dark
and
of course it's also true that ongoing
pain and illness is
not just hard to take for the other
people in your life
one of the hardest things for the person
experiencing it is the realization that
it's fundamentally boring for the other
people in your life it's boring for you
too of course but
do that reports that he would run into
people or see people online
that he hadn't seen in many months or
even a couple of years
and they would be surprised like wait
you're still you're still dealing with
that
um there's like there's a disappointment
and indeed a sense that somehow you must
be doing this to yourself
um or that you're
exaggerating and uh it's it that's not
helpful when you're experiencing
something that you can't control you
can't diagnose no one is diagnosing for
you and you're just miserable to be met
also with the disappointment and yes
boredom of of those who love you so
there's that's that's one of the themes
running throughout the book and it's
it's quite remarkably well done
um
and here's a spoiler but not really
because it emerges very early in the
book it turns out that do that had has
still lyme disease
and
there's a lot to say here
but for me the book really gets
interesting
well actually i'm going to read a few
short passages
early in the book
without any more introduction
i will say also i have the advanced
uncorrected proofs they're sending me
the final book i don't have it yet
so
it's possible this isn't exactly what's
in the final book but it's it's quite
good
the consensus around lyme disease was
sealed in 1991 when there were enough
new reported cases 10 000 and climbing
for the centers for disease control to
begin national surveillance for lyme
establish formal diagnostic criteria and
endorse a two-tier testing regimen the
elisa test followed by the western blot
two different ways of looking for lyme
antibodies in the patient's blood
diagnostic standardization was supposed
to establish a consistent baseline for
national case reporting not rule out the
possibility of atypical cases or
constrained doctors from diagnosing them
but in practice it did exactly that
narrowing the range of cases that
counted as real lime by encouraging
doctors to limit their diagnoses to a
cdc-approved set of symptoms mostly
visible manifestations like joint
swelling and the famous rash
meanwhile the testing rules had a
similar effect the two-tier approach
reduced the risk of false positives but
it created a larger chance of false
negatives missing anywhere from a third
to half of early lyme cases and as many
as 25 of cases even in late stage
neurologic line
the incentive structures forged by the
cdc were a fascinating case study in how
bureaucracy shapes science as much as
the other way around how without any
conscious decision let alone conspiracy
scientific research can end up pushed
again and again down the same well-worn
tracks
the narrow diagnostic criteria became
the benchmark not just for doctors
treating patients but for researchers
when they applied for public grants so
that lyme research increasingly focused
on only the most certain diagnoses and
left all ambiguous cases and potential
false negatives alone
this approach ratified the
establishment's confidence in their own
rules of evidence a study might show
that most lyme patients had the typical
presentations clear blood tests
consistent early symptoms but only after
making one or more of these
presentations a prerequisite for being
admitted to the study in the first place
likewise after 1991 insurance companies
began to deny payment for lyme cases
that didn't meet the cdc criteria
if you were a doctor who wanted to
diagnose or treat more broadly you
basically had to become a medical
outsider a maverick the sort of weird
specialist who didn't take insurance who
risked scrutiny from state medical
boards and so on down a list of
attributes that self-selected for
eccentricity stubbornness and a touch of
crankery
so the cdc guidelines essentially
ratified the split already opening in
the 1980s between an official
understanding of the disease and a
dissenting view between a medical
establishment that felt satisfied with
how it diagnosed and treated this novel
seeming pathogen and a growing
population of patients and sufferers or
self-described sufferers at least who
felt ignored abandoned and betrayed
it created not just two world views but
two cultures two concentric circles of
insiders and outsiders the inner one
confident and authoritative and bored by
institutional support
the outer one more fluid and open-minded
but also necessarily more peculiar and
paranoid and sometimes frankly gonzo and
its theories and experiments there are
even two different medical associations
the infectious diseases society of
america issued the mainstream guidelines
while the dissenters formed the
international lyme and associated
diseases society which issued
recommendations of its own
um
let me read the few other uh excerpts
before before we talk about this so i'll
say i've i read the book and you have
not read it but i've been talking to you
about it as i've been reading it
much later in the book
i won't say what page it is because i'm
not sure the pages will be consistent
between my version and the published
version
just this a data set can be meaningful
and useful and suggestive in other words
even if it falls short of the standards
that are set by official medicine in its
bureaucratized safety first contemporary
form
then this
let me offer a note of optimism if there
is one thing that makes the chronic lyme
world different from other realms of
alternative or outsider medicine it's
the centrality of antibiotics a
peridigmatic insider approved treatments
to its preferred cure
often in medical debates the pattern is
reversed the established recommends
antibiotics the outsiders and mavericks
worry that they're overprescribed the
holistic types warn about their side
effects
but with lyme it's the establishment
that retreats to mystery while the
dissenters are yelling about how we
already have the necessary drugs
three
more sorry looking for it
so at the end of the book
i had actually i'd reached out to the
publisher to ask if it would be okay if
i would talk about this as i didn't
imagine
um
that the author was going to talk about
covet at all given
i i just didn't see any evidence of it
um and i wanted to make some connections
to our current environment and it turns
out he does and it turns out he got
coveted
and
he uh
he and his son
took the tests and
um
his son's test was botched and therefore
was inclusive while his was negative he
says a past version of myself might have
been tempted to believe the result the
new version the one accustomed to
inconclusive tests and self-doctoring
considered my distinctive symptoms
plus my family's dissentive symptoms
plus the timing plus the fact that tests
at that point had at least a 40 false
negative rate and felt entirely
comfortable with self-diagnosis on and
on and on he uses a number of the
alternative treatments to which he has
he feels that he's been forced and now
is finding some relief and with regard
to lyme
um to try for his for his covid and he
says
and long before it was picked up by
donald trump back when it was just an
internet theory based on french and
chinese trials i knew all about
hydroxychloroquine which have been
prescribed to me by the reassurer his
pseudonym for one of his doctors long
ago in a bottle that still had a few
pills remaining which i now found and
took
and he took a few things he doesn't know
what worked but he knows he got better
very fast
two more sentences two more very brief
excerpts
from the beginning of the pandemic to
its still unfinished end there were
weirdos on the internet
that's us
who were more reliable guides to what
was happening what was possible and what
should actually be done than anthony
fauci or any other official information
source
and finally on nearly the last page of
the book maybe yeah
very near the end of the book
it's completely understandable that the
medical establishment doesn't want to
officially endorse any of the various
unproven paths
but there's a difference between
declining to endorse a single path and
ruling further treatment out entirely a
difference between acknowledging the
diversity of case studies and claiming
that no lessons can be drawn from the
diverse attempts to treat them
wow no shortage of lessons here no
shortage of lessons and so you see why
i think i had just finished it uh at the
point that we were on air last week and
i was thinking so much about
the lessons that we can learn from how
lime you know we are we've we had
students with long line which is now how
i've come to come to think about long
line long coved which do that clearly
has
and um you know like with cobin
very many people are asymptomatic and
very many other people actually follow
the cdc mainstream you
know course of of symptoms and get
better quickly and some number of people
don't
and the idea that those people are there
for making things up or shouldn't be um
trying other things or should be forced
into the fringes of the medical
establishment often forced therefore in
the u.s because of our crappy health
care system our crappy insurance system
forced to pay out of pocket
um in their attempts to do things uh
that will probe that in some cases in
some cases he reports helped him even
though there is no you know
there are no rcts for many of these
treatments right there's not even
published research for some of them and
yet there's a whole
internet of people
who find uh evidence that things work
and indeed he found some things that
worked and some things that didn't and
part of the
welcome to complex systems
some things will work for some people
and they will not work for others and
that is to be expected yeah this is
exactly what i was going to say is that
this is actually even if we just look at
you know an honorable smart system
trying to do the right thing there's a
fundamental problem at the at the ground
floor here which is very difficult to
solve which is let's say so first of all
we should distinguish between a
pathology and a syndrome
right a pathology
is an actual mechanistic description of
how something goes wrong
a syndrome is a list of symptoms that
seem to go along with something and so
very often if let's say that you there's
a pathogen circulating
but we haven't seen it yet it's very
hard to isolate a pathogen and if you
isolate a pathogen it's very hard to
know if it's a co-traveler with
something that's causing a disease
whether it is causing the disease right
these are
famously hard things to establish
so you very often have a list of
symptoms that doctors start to notice
showing up together
and then there's a question about what
might be causing it and actually you you
and i will remember
back when aids had been spotted but hiv
was unknown
there was a
huge
very strange at the time effort to
figure out what it was were gay men
doing something
were they encountering some chemical
right was it was something involved in
bath houses right right what was it
right we didn't know and um you know and
even after hiv was discovered
even from
very respectable people like kerry
mullis there was a question about
whether hiv was actually causal of the
disease aids or was just simply
correlated with it or
something else but nonetheless the point
is
humans are complex
immune systems are complex
people get
dysfunction of all kinds of origins
right you can have a defective gene and
it can cause a cascade of things to fail
downstream of it and you may therefore
look like you have the same disease as
somebody who has a pathology that has
interrupted the same pathway right so
indeed the point is
when do you know
a doctor noticing a set of symptoms that
go together might be looking at two
diseases two doctors that see the same
list of symptoms now have something the
basis of what might be a pattern it
could also be a total coincidence once
you start recognizing these things
people who have mysterious ailments may
spot the list of symptoms that overlaps
what they have and discount the other
ones because they want someone to pay
attention to their problems so it
becomes necessary to set out a set of
criteria to say actually these are the
people who have the thing that we're
trying to study and understand and these
people have something else right but
then once you set that up as as do that
points out you now have a circular
problem which is you're including only
people who have the established list in
your study sample and that means that to
the extent there's something you need to
learn from the people who have you know
three extra symptoms or two fewer
symptoms you won't learn it this is the
problem with throwing out um this is the
problem with the very concept of
outliers
at some level and you know we're not and
and do that's argument and yours and
ours before has been actually it's not
even there's one
crazy erroneous case you're like i'm
looking at a data set and it's got
thousands and there's you know
a few things that are so far outside
that we're just not going to pay
attention to those it's that so often
the borders of our categories are drawn
too early and somewhat arbitrarily
and
the idea that for instance oh well yes
you had lyme but if you still have lyme
six months later then it's something
else even though your symptoms are the
same like well that's
that's that alone is a very crazy
declaration and that and that apparently
is something that that both do that and
other people with long line experience
like oh yes we right we will acknowledge
that you had it but given that it's gone
on far longer than we recognized lime
everlast therefore you now have
something that we're calling sort of you
know post-lyme syndrome where i don't
remember exactly what it's called but um
which is which is itself a rather
remarkable declaration
i don't even know that it is though
actually because you we are always in
the case of a pathogen that causes a
disease
we are always dealing with an arms race
where the pathogen and the immune system
duke it out
and the point is there are certain
canonical strategies that
work right like
moving into tissue that is outside of
the range of the immune system moving
into neurological tissue for example to
hide from the immune system
is a strategy that many viruses use
and that means that they can be present
and not detectable right because they're
shielded it also puts the immune system
in an interesting predicament which is
ordinarily the immune systems like the
cartoon job that we describe in in
introduction to immunology
is they distinguish self versus non-self
and they attack anything that looks
biological that is non-self but that
creates a selective force that drives
pathogens in the direction of looking
like self in order to hide from the
immune system which then raises the
possibility of autoimmune disorder and
so it is you know and you know we heard
or to be you know other in self's
clothing right right to cloak themselves
exactly exactly but you know and we
heard from uh
pierre cory when he was on the podcast
that um you know in the case of covid
right the actual
uh pathogens presence may be short-lived
relative to the disease because a lot of
the disease are the cascading
inflammatory effects that continue on
afterwards and so all these things are
on the table and probably 20 others that
you know are harder to describe
and what
here's here's what i think the punchline
of all of this is
long ago
a hundred years ago
doctors were scientists
that's what they were and they had a
much smaller toolkit
but they were
better at wielding it because their job
was actually to spend enough time
looking at patterns and you know i used
people right by spending time with their
actual patients in in their physical
presence for longer and often in their
homes in their homes exactly and so the
idea of a doctor who had a much smaller
range of drugs they could prescribe
about which less was known right
that doctor nonetheless had the ability
to detect patterns and there you know
there's this very famous example of
cholera being discussed discovered in a
water source in which the key piece of
evidence was the geographic distribution
of cases right
um
but
but if memory serves i think that
discovery was done by
not one of the very local people i think
someone came in and basically started
mapping it out i think that's okay i
can't remember it's a very famous story
i just don't remember the specifics but
how often is something like this the
case which you don't see when people
come into your office and you know how
often does the doctor look at your
address and say huh
that's the fourth one of those cases
i've seen from this neighborhood and i
haven't seen one from anywhere else i
wonder if there's arsenic in something
right or yeah i mean i think
more likely to be explanatory is
you know the doctor walks into the
patient's home and wrinkles his nose
right like
do you have mold or oh you've got eight
parakeets maybe you've got a bird
allergy like whatever whatever it is or
uh or oh you've got how many times does
that train that just rattled your
windows go by and you say you're
sensitive to light and noise you know
there's just a num so many things that
you can learn about what could actually
be affecting someone's health by seeing
them where they live obviously i mean
this is this is the most obvious thing
ever right by seeing them where they
live and being empowered i mean i think
what people don't they can't fathom
right we have this very
i think foolish relationship with the
idea of intuition
right when people mention intuition it's
like they're treading right at the
border of the mystical
something mystical about this right
intuition is an unconscious process that
is either well informed or poorly
informed by what the person has
experienced right and so a person who
has a lot of experience with something
may have a very powerful intuition that
that's the place to search and that
isn't and they're likely to be right not
because something came from outside but
because they perceived accurately but
this i this is super important i think i
think the reason that people
many people think oh that's mystical is
because
they have divided the world into two
categories
that which is understandable by science
and already understood
and everything else which is somehow
mystical or woo and you know depending
on their particular predilections either
therefore none of that is real or
therefore we just don't know anything
about it and the i you know what what
you were saying and we would argue is
um
intuition is is you
understanding something about the world
that you don't yet have the words for
and it may be that actually science does
have language for what it is that you've
you've perceived and how it is that
you've done it and maybe science doesn't
but that doesn't mean just because
science does or does not know yet what
it is that you have done to get to the
knowledge that you have that it lives in
some ethereal spirit world right it's
the mistake of
us categorizing the mind as synonymous
effectively with the conscious mind
which is actually a tiny fraction of the
mind right even the thinking there's
lots of the mind that is dedicated to
doing stuff that doesn't have anything
to do really with thought but there's a
lot of thought that goes on outside of
the realm of the consciously perceived
so for example let's say you knew
somebody
and you know let's say they were
basically honest but they lied about
some topic right
and
you might begin to pick up something it
might be that their vocal cords tense
just slightly differently when they're
in that lying phase they have a lot of
tells right exactly and so you may not
know if let's say that it is a frequency
issue that the color the tone color in
their voices is just slightly solid
frequency right right
even if you did there was something in
their voice it might be that the only
thing you could actually say consciously
is there's something about their voice
that's a little different but you might
not be able to say no there's less in
this register or right most of us don't
even have the language for it so
so the point is a well-tutored intuition
is actually the most important thing for
somebody who knows a lot about a
difficult topic right you really want
them to use their well-tutored intuition
to limit the search space and the point
is that doctors are being disempowered
to be scientists right they're becoming
practitioners of something that is
algorithmic right when a person has
these symptoms they have this disorder
which is treated with this
pharmaceutical and the point is it's a
very automatic process and we are now in
the context of covid watching it become
even more automatic as doctors are being
robbed of their ability for example to
prescribe things off label but the point
is in a complex system yes you need
somebody with an excellent intuition to
come into your situation and to spot
that although you have these symptoms
which overlap the description of this
disease you also have this other thing
which puts you in some separate rarer
category perhaps and you need somebody
empowered to do that and that's
frightening because you can't tell
whether somebody is capable of it based
on their degree no
it's a skill beyond what can actually be
described and tested right so you know
just like we talk
sometimes in the context of science
about somebody having lab hands right
right lab hands is like muscle memory it
doesn't really exist but it's very
important no but it does and you know
i've had a number of um healthcare
practitioners in the in the wake of the
boat accident and you know all all of
the
all of the bodywork that i've had done
which includes people from um do's you
know osteopathic doctors prescribing
privileges i haven't used them but um
you know through you know through
structural integration and
myofascial work and strain counter
strain and just you know a lot of
different kinds of work
some of
everyone who might have asked
has said some version of
i can you know i want to know the
science i want to understand what it is
that we know about why it is that my
particular approach works um but in what
given what it is that i do you also need
to have the hands and it's not clear to
me that that can be taught and some of
these people have actually tried to
teach you know have had proteges have
tried to mentor others
and have said um you know with with
sadness oh you know i had this one
person who was so you know so book smart
so brilliant so capable of understanding
why it is that this non-mainstream
medical technique in this case it was
strained counter-strain
is so effective and yet for the life of
me i could not teach her the hands like
she did not have the touch and you know
she was
my the person who was working on me
had her protege working on her and had
her working on other clients she said
she just she cannot find she cannot find
the spots
and there is there is reality to that
whether or not
whether or not you like the language not
sounding fully quantitative in sciency
there is reality to it
and it's in many ways the most important
reality yeah i wonder there's probably
somebody who has a systematic way of
understanding this but there are many
things and i think to me there's a
difference between
can it be mentored and can it be taught
right the most important things are
things that can be mentored but cannot
be taught
right how do you formulate a good
hypothesis for
a complex set of observations
i do not know
there's no method
you can use to describe how that is done
right it is a creative process and
nowhere in talking about how science
works
you know do we talk about the art of
generating a hypothesis in fact we
pretend it isn't an art because that
sounds embarrassing well it's creative
and it's intuitive it's creative it's
intuitive it involves a tolerance for
crazy fanciful ideas that quickly fall
apart you have to be ready to traffic in
that at least in your own mind in order
to get to the idea that's actually
robust enough to be worth voicing and a
tolerance for a period of whatever
domain it is that you're interested in
i think this exists for most people i
know it did for me
for me famously
as you know this story and as i write
about in my first book in antipode
you know being walked into the lowland
tropical rainforest in costa rica uh for
the first time as would be scientists we
had already traveled a fair bit but um
with john vandermeer the professor that
we were in costa rica with along with
four other grad students he sort of
spread his arms wide and said look at
all the questions
and i was like god it just looks green i
don't see any questions i just see a lot
of leaves i don't know what's going on
here and but i was i was fascinated i
was driven i was excited by what i did
see
it just didn't come in the form of
questions at first and it took
it took
so much time it took just so much time
troning my hypothesis i my hypothesis
brain and my scientific eye
and um and observational skills
and just sitting sitting and being in
the place where i was interested in
learning how to do pattern recognition
and waiting for the patterns to reveal
themselves and for some people it
doesn't
or they don't have the patience or turns
out it's not the work they want to be
doing yeah and i think for some people
with regard to the hands with regard to
bodywork regardless of how much they
think they want to do it it may just not
come to them right well yeah there's
some things that you can't
some people are
the the
uh window of opportunity has passed
before you ever get around to saying hey
can you do this thing yeah i remember
john saying
do you see all the questions and
boy did i yeah you did right then i mean
at some level
it is not intuitive how it wouldn't be
obvious that all of that pattern is
basic you couldn't possibly sort all of
the questions that are suggested even by
just that one static scene right the
distribution of stuff but
um but anyway
you can mentor this
and
you know you and i did a lot of
exploring of
what good teaching space looked like and
uh how it actually worked and it was
surprising how often there was something
useful to say that was just borrowed
from some realm that wasn't supposed to
be relevant right like uh immersion
language biology is not linear the way
some other topics are
there's nowhere to start right if you
walked into a forest and you say well
where do you start there's nowhere to
start you can start anywhere because it
all
leads to everything else and you have to
start somewhere which means that your
first question is going to be shockingly
out of context but
um and you're quickly going to discover
all the demands you know nothing about
and have to just shut down some of them
be like i can't i can't know all the
domains right
um in terms of the difference between
mentoring and teaching i never figured
out the first useful thing to say about
how you formulate a hypothesis but you
can play a game which is you can put the
pattern in front of somebody you can say
here's a pattern i don't know why it's
there and neither do you
what are some hypotheses that might work
and then you can you can do something
that's more like
volleying
right you know i guess i don't um i
disagree with the dichotomy here i don't
think that's not teaching no it is it's
well the i like mentoring better because
it is teaching but the point is teaching
to me
suggests
we know how this is conveyed rather than
you're going to have to discover how
this is conveyed you're going to have to
discover how this is done on your side
and your method may not look like
anybody else's nor will you necessarily
be able to describe it well
i guess i am going to be stubborn here
and say just like
the word feminism and even more so the
word woman for instance like i'm going
to hang on to those words and i'm not
going to let the new the the version
that is passing for standard
increasingly um take over and so
teaching it's been you know decades now
the teaching is largely done the way
that you're talking about it uh but i
think you know what we were doing in the
classrooms
uh was
a combination of a lot of things
including a very lot of what you're
talking about and it was all education
sure it's all education but the the
problem is if you know if mentoring and
teaching are effectively synonymous
we're not getting the full value out of
the fact that there are two terms that
have a different connotation
and i think the point is there's a lot
of stuff that can be taught
right and then there's a lot of stuff
that must be learned
that cannot be taught and is not
it is not hopeless to convey something
useful but that the process right the
process by which the tennis pro
teaches
the uh
the player who is learning to play
right does not involve
it it just simply involves the tennis
pro returning
the volleys of the student
such that the student gets better and
better over time right but that's still
teaching i mean i i think this is
ultimately a non-interesting semantic
argument but i feel like what you're
what you're putting into the category
teaching is that which can already be
described and it's exactly what we talk
about when we say you know what that
thing where you're conflating the
products of science with what science is
that's not true and so you know oh the
the thing that we can describe fully as
if by litany or as a recipe only that is
the stuff that can be taught i i'm not
interested in foregoing all of the
things for which there is you know about
which there is uncertainty and where
serendipity is important and creativity
and intuition and where discovery is
part of the point
uh yeah we
that is that is where an education that
you know encouraging that behavior and
facilitating people in their engagement
with those sorts of behaviors is what an
education should be because all the rest
of it you can google right but i i guess
i don't understand
it seems to me i'm not saying
to surrender on that stuff i'm saying
the most important stuff is the mentored
stuff which is the stuff that cannot be
made methodological
right and so the point is it's the
hardest stuff to teach if that's the
word we're going to use and so i just
think that i mean you know we can we can
let it go but i think the category of
mentorship is where the most important
stuff is done and it may be that you
need to teach a bunch of stuff to get to
the point where mentoring is necessary
right we may need to teach you to do
arithmetic before we
mentor you in
traversing a frontier in mathematics
but
that
if we synonymize the two then it becomes
very confusing because the point is
people are you know people are seeking
uh someone to teach them how to do
things that may not be teachable they
may be only mentorable yeah i'm not
arguing for synonymizing i think i just
have different definitions of both of
these terms than you do and um i don't
want i don't want to forego i don't want
to lose within teaching um
so much of the most valuable part of
what education is it feels like it's a
it is a devaluation of teaching but you
i feel like we're making some point more
well my my point was
the idea of a system that is going to
rob doctors of their autonomy yes and
their ability to um
navigate the unknown and say medicine
has figured out what we do with people
no matter what symptoms they walk
through the door with there's a yeah you
know there's a checklist that we can go
through that will tell you exactly what
pill to send them out the door with and
the answer is no that's never been good
medicine
and it's especially bad now because
we're dealing with such a large range of
novel
inputs and such an increased exposure to
a variety of pathogens based on the way
we travel around the world and all so
what you need is the easiest way for
medicine to make money is with pills
right it's the it's the easy thing which
is you know this happened in psychology
too right we went from
people who you know traversed the
uh the workings of the mind based on
talking with them which of course can't
be systematized right right to oh you
know here are the six you know any three
of these six criteria you mean you have
such and such disorder and here's the
pill that fixes that because of course
we know so much about neurobiology that
we can just drop a pill on it and fix
you because you've got bad genes for
your teeth that explains your teeth and
you've also got a serotonin deficiency
or so you're not making enough serotonin
you're making too much serotonin yeah
it's it's it's this it's the same kind
of absurd reductionist metric driven
anti-scientific argument that passes for
medicine or psychiatry or whatever it is
passing for it is shoehorning
the truly complex into these simple
rubrics in order it basically flatters
your ability to fix stuff and then of
course those fixes don't really work
right like maybe you find yeah some pill
that has you know arbitrary large
effects across the brain and of course
it disrupts whatever pathology you have
going on among other things and it may
cause three others but we've got pills
for those too right we got pills for
those two and it may turn out that the
effect isn't all that useful because it
was just basically distracting and then
it's temporary but addictive
right so anyway that all of these things
have the same damn error and the answer
is you know human beings haven't gotten
any simpler and and
the environment hasn't gotten any less
noisy so
you know we need we need people with
really well-tutored intuition that comes
from
exposure to a wide range of
examples and we they need to be free
that's the thing in order to do the job
well they have to be free
and we're doing the opposite to them we
are doing the opposite to them
indeed
should we move on sure uh
maybe this is the place for the one note
that i wanted to add in here follow on
to it depends on what your note is about
i don't know it's about a closely
related topic i also have closely
related topics but you go okay so the
closely related topic has to do with
artificial consensus okay right from
which we talked about a little bit last
week
and i wanted to follow up on the story
of the paper by jessica rose and peter
mccullough on myocarditis following
covet vaccination
people who watched last week will
remember
that this paper had passed peer review
and was headed towards publication
when the elsevier journal cardiology
journal
replaced the preprint of the paper with
a note saying it had been temporarily
moved
and that
if it was not fully restored the new
version of the paper
would contain an explanation of why it
was temporarily removed
and
we pointed out how unusual this was this
wasn't a paper being rejected because of
some issue this wasn't the authors were
literally not told what the problem was
that was highly unusual
and
in any case it suggested some kind of
behind the scenes shenanigans that we
are left to guess at and of course on a
topic where we are told there's a
scientific consensus and you should
follow it and the answer is well why is
there a scientific consensus here's a
paper that ran against that consensus
and suddenly mysterious things are
happening to it and i must say many
people wagged their finger at me when i
tweeted about this and said you're
imagining things stuff goes on all the
time with papers there's a problem with
this that or the other it all turns out
to be nonsense and what has happened in
the intervening week what has happened
in the interviewing what has happened in
the interviewing week exactly
yeah i am glad you asked thank you
zach do you want to put up the uh
the
i want you to put up the correspondence
so what we have here can you put it on a
bigger screen so we can read it
so what this is is a letter from current
problems in cardiology
uh it's still too small
it's a letter to peter mccullough
in which the journal is explaining that
in fact they have rejected this paper
now rejecting a paper is not so unusual
but rejecting a paper after you have
accepted a paper is unusual
no explanation is given for why this has
taken place and what happens is that the
journal is simply asserting that they
have the right to do this
yes there's no explanation
so for those
people are going to be looking at my
nose here i hate that the screen is way
up there i can get them to close their
eyes
dear dr mccullough this is dated october
21st thank you for your email of 15th of
october i am afraid that the journal is
not willing to publish the paper we do
not agree that there has been any sort
of breach here the publishing agreement
that was signed attached contains the
following clause which makes it clear
that articles may be rejected at a late
stage in the publication process the
editor's decision to project the paper
is final and all rights have reverted to
use that you are free to submit the
paper to another journal
and the paragraph on reversion of rights
reads articles may sometimes be accepted
for publication but later rejected in
the publication process even in some
cases after public posting in articles
in press form in which case all rights
will revert to the author
c
link yours sincerely diana
so again i just want to emphasize how
unusual it is for no reason to be given
right it definitely suggests that
something has happened behind the scenes
and in light of the contentious nature
of the
phenomena in question
it appears to be the construction of the
appearance of consensus by
the targeting of anything that goes in
the other direction i mean among among
other things as as deeply flawed as peer
review is
had this paper been rejected at peer
review the authors would have been given
the three sets of comments by the peer
reviewers and they may have been banal
and cryptic and uninformative but there
would have been something there and
there
some justification is required when a
peer reviewer says no i don't think you
should publish this paper so here we had
you know two or three peer reviewers who
said yes publish the journal published
and then pulled it and there's no
there's not even any information that
would be found in you know largely not
very useful negative peer review there's
there's nothing i've i've actually just
as you said last week never heard of
anything like this now you know i'm not
in the weeds on peer review and journals
at this point but i was for many years
and this strikes me as
extraordinarily unusual right so i would
point out um
i accidentally borrowed a phrase from
eric that i didn't realize i had
borrowed at the time but the phrase is
follow the silence and in this case this
is a clear example what you've got now
is an absent journal article right a
journal article that points in the
direction of a pathology
following on from
vaccination that is worth knowing about
obviously whether or not to
mandate vaccines would require a
cost-benefit analysis which would
require us to know what the harms are to
be able to calibrate how common they are
how serious they are all of these things
it requires this evaluation and so in
any case what i would say is
it is intolerable
that
thoroughly qualified scientists and
doctors are having publications that
have passed peer review that have done
everything correctly eliminated from the
record before they even emerge without
explanation so we can't even evaluate
for ourselves whether or not this
journal has made some discovery that's
important about this publication or not
presumably it hasn't or it would have
said what the problem was
um so
in any case i think the point is
read the books that they want to burn
right that's the way that we win against
the censorship read the books that they
want to burn right seek out the stuff
that they don't want you to see talk to
the people that you're supposed to not
listen to right that is the way to
figure out whether there is something
there of importance or whether it truly
is nothing this is actually a perfect
segue i wasn't going to do this next but
zack if you would show my screen this is
a washington post article from
yesterday from october
that would be the 22nd
i don't know what day it is anymore
uh it is october
thanks
what's up
zack your father is endlessly helpful
okay i have the sense you're being
ironic so at the washington post as we
all know democracy dies in darkness here
is an article published on october 22 of
2021 called five tactics used to spread
vaccine misinformation in the wellness
community and why they work
so
i'm sorry for the
vertigo inducing scroll here um
this is online and i'll link to it in
the show notes but i'm just using my pdf
so i could
uh so i can show you highlighted
sections two little sections taking
science out of context this is their
third of five points of you know how the
wellness community is
causing problems in um basically uh
compliance
uh with public health pronouncements
taking science out of context
the public is observing the scientific
method up close and in real time
i'm gonna read that first sentence again
the public is observing the scientific
method up close and in real time
since when
the [ __ ] are they talking sorry like
what are they what are they talking
about i mean this has been our point
from the beginning like early on in like
march april may 2020 when the pre-print
servers were buzzing like they were so
full of papers
and
those of us who were interested and you
know felt that we had the chops to wade
in and read those papers it was amazing
it really did feel like the wild west in
the best sense of the word right like
you could see
what people were finding what they
thought it meant and watch hypotheses
being tested and thrown out and not
falsified and you tested again and it
was amazing and that stopped
like
we're not seeing that anymore right and
never was at the mainstream media
the public is observing the scientific
method up close and in real time no it's
not
no it's not this is a flat out lie or
actually more likely in this case not a
lie washington post and the new york
times and npr and cnn and you know all
the rest
maybe actually believe this
they think that if you come out wearing
a lab coat or just flashing your letters
like phd or md or whatever and say i say
the same thing that everyone else has
said that you're seeing the science
the scientific method up close in real
time bull
[ __ ]
sorry
okay next paragraph from this paper from
this article in wapo in washington post
another tactic is cherry picking data
for example some will point to the
vaccine adverse event reporting system
known as fairs as evidence of widespread
deaths and injuries from vaccines while
ignoring the broadly acknowledged
limitation of its data
one of the broadly acknowledged
limitations so what do we have then
point us to the source of data on what
would be adverse events
unless you're literally claiming there
are none
and then we can talk yeah the one source
of data that is possible the only
objection is well but it's flawed
prove it's flawed but also until and
unless there's another system in place
are you seriously comfortable with the
idea that there is actually no way to
collect data at all on adverse events
and that's going to be fine yeah it's
amazing they've they've left us with a
situation in which their argument
amounts to the thing that suggests
there's a serious problem isn't good
enough to be relied on leaving us with
no information it's very much like what
what do that was running with regard to
lyme disease
right
so you were taking notes while i was
ranting uh are you done ranting uh you
know i i can i you know yeah i could
rant from no no if you're done right i
just i wanted to oh um let me see did i
want to say anything else
um yeah just just that where it's quite
the opposite we're not being allowed
we're being shoved
having conclusions shoved down our
throats which is exactly the opposite of
the scientific process we are being told
that whatever the little bit of data
that we can see isn't real data so don't
pay attention to that we're not being
shown the analysis of anyone who claims
to come to conclusions those people who
come to conclusions that are different
from the mainstream like uh is it rose
and mccullough
have their papers disappeared with no
explanation
so we're seeing the scientific process
up close and personal no we're not no
quite the opposite exactly the opposite
and if you think we are
you have accepted a very large lie yeah
if anything if you're paying attention
you're seeing what upends the science
process happening uh in front of your
eyes but it's all too easy to ignore
yeah well what i was thinking was you
know last where i should confess to the
audience that we are with our children
uh
please don't send child protective
services our children are old enough to
handle it we are watching
mad men with our children we've watched
it before it's extraordinary it tells it
it explains a little too much about some
of the mess the world is in now it
explains a lot but in any case it has
this kind of an advertising frame of
mind and last week we proposed a slogan
for the uh
youtube uh
community guidelines folks youtube
community guidelines because you can't
handle the truth and i have one here the
washington post
this is free work they're entitled to
use it i grant them rights if they would
like to replace ourselves
i am a very generous person the new
slogan i'm proposing it's a variation on
the theme they've already got is
democracy dies in darkness as will you
if you don't get on board with the
sanctioned
public narrative
right maybe in room 101
in room one for example for example for
example one of many possible outcomes
yeah um not making any promises though
that's good i mean maybe
it means compressing yeah it's it's
worthy it's wordy
motto it's a little wordy but you know
so are they yes this piece that i just
read from is just goes on and on and on
and on and those may have been those
were the ones that popped out at me as
the most egregious but the whole thing
is garbage it's just it's just garbage
argument after garbage argument and what
they're trying to do is convince you
that you have if you have thoughts that
don't fit with what they have already
told you you need to think that it's
because you're being misled it's
probably because you're stupid you're
maybe not educated enough uh you've
probably fallen prey to some some
hucksters and weirdos online
and you know are there hucksters and
weirdos online yeah of course they're
hucksters and weirdos in
the political system and the medical
system and everywhere and
what you need to do
is embrace the concept of thinking for
yourself and actually try to assess the
arguments that you hear from everyone as
much as possible from data from first
principles from logic and then try out
what you have arrived at on your friends
on your family on you know yourself in
your worst moment say you know what
what would what would i have to see that
would falsify this thing that i now
think is true
do that
no you don't just accept the word with
the guy who has the degree or the lab
coat or the glassware no that's not
getting to the scientific process up
close and personal quite the opposite
um
yeah yeah no i think
i feel better a little bit okay um
this is okay so this this paper
interesting just banging on all sorts of
god
trying to get the groom and the bride to
kiss or something
isn't that what you do
zach bring someone home i will find out
okay okay uh
here's a paper out this week
here it is i just show my screen briefly
brett brett zack
god okay yep um
research article in science heuristics
in the in the delivery room
and
actually i'll just
read the the
no actually i won't
heuristics in the delivery room so give
me my screen back if you will zachary
thank you
this is a this is a very interesting
piece of research
obstetricians about obstetricians the
obstetricians to which i referred at the
top of the hour
helping women through labor and delivery
l d have a lot of moving parts to assess
obviously it's high stakes high stress
job
one of
uh one of the things that they have to
decide is what kind of delivery women
are going to have the two
basically the two there's probably other
options but basically vaginal or
c-section cesarean section
uh the first being the norm whether or
not it's and then under certain
circumstances um c-section is
required and of course there's a whole
lot of literature and thinking on how um
there's a rise in c-sections um over the
last several decades i think has
actually begun to begin to reverse uh
because it was sort of it was
too often done for convenience and um to
be able to time birth rather than
actually for the good of the
mother and the child but this research
finds
that
if an obstetrician i'll just i'll put it
in a hypothetical term which is not what
the paper does um
if an obstetrician has two deliveries in
one day
and um
the mother's uh the first mother has a
vaginal birth but she has complications
that were unexpected
that obstetrician going to the second
birth is more likely to direct that
mother to and to give that mother a
cesarean section
than if the first mother had not had
complications
from a v-birth
which is
both alarming and so very human
right so it's
it is
you know the two mothers presumably have
no risk factors in common and certainly
the original research made sure that
that was the case um precluding maybe
you know something about the hospital
environment that is making one or the
other type of delivery particularly
dangerous in which case that would be a
broader scale problem than just this
obstetrician where you know any any
hospital but a very rural place is going
to have more than one obstetrician
working at a time
so the idea that um whether or not you
get shunted into one of the other kinds
of modes of delivery is in part
predicted by whether or not your
obstetrician's previous delivery had
complications that he or she wasn't
expecting
is um something that women going into
labor and delivery and their partners
and their support
people need to know right um
but it also points to me um to like i
said this kind of
human universal right that
people
tend to assume dependence between events
that don't have dependence
right there's no way that two women
um
who happened to be giving birth at the
same time in the same say you know urban
hospital inherently have similar risk
factors that were unusual on the first
one that would prov that would um
make uh a particular birth more like
more difficult let's slow down slightly
yeah okay
so first of all i just want to point out
this is a very elegant uh
it's more or less a natural experiment i
hesitate to use the term because usually
natural experiment is like different
populations on a series of islands or
something like that and then obviously
there's nothing natural about a hospital
but
the idea that the data is generated by
just a series of events
it's an observational it's an
observational study that
compares two things and assuming
a
rational model of hazards in uh in
giving birth
then this does seem to reveal
a
non-medical
pattern yes right this is a pattern of
human psychology not a pattern of
medical need and it's one with important
consequences because these two versions
of birth are not uh equivalent in terms
of their hazards and benefits
on the other hand i mean
there let's just try to find a mechanism
by which this would actually be rational
that's plausible
now i've got one i don't believe it for
a second but i know that formally it
works okay so let's say that there is a
lot more about
complications in birth that has to do
with the obstetrician
right if the obstetrician is detecting
oh i the obstetrician i'm having an off
day
and as much as i don't like to do
c-sections i don't want to have a
complication
that's unnecessary so although it's it's
more risky on average when i'm having an
off day it's actually the safer of the
two options
right
then you could find this pattern and
that in fact would be medical in nature
yep um that's that's true if if the
complications
are downstream of obstetrical behavior
then um this would actually be a perhaps
a a
good finding a benef of benefit to the
mothers who were later in the day i'm
struggling over the language too because
if this were our native territory the
point is this pattern is either adaptive
or not yeah right in this case i'm using
medical as a substitute meaning you know
to the benefit of the patient
um
again i don't believe for a second that
that's what's going on because i think
much more often the complications are
about you know
uh cord wrapped around the baby's neck
well and the over-medicalization of the
process in the first place like you know
lying down highly drugged
uh you know don't move at all be while
you're in labor you know there's just a
whole lot of stuff that will tend to
cause births to become sluggish and slow
and then ultimately at the point the
mother's super exhausted things don't go
right instead of you know okay get up
walk around you know
you know let's let's hasten this process
which is
which is much more likely to result in a
safe
excruciating you know but um
faster
and um
non-complicating vaginal birth yes i
will also say as much as i am a firm
believer that there is some good method
that we could you know if we were
completely open-minded about what
actually works and what actually doesn't
and we you know didn't talk ourselves
out of stuff i bet you could find
exactly that walk around method or
whatever it is or i know the russians
were experimenting with
uh
births into into water and
who knows um but the point is it may
also be that some of this is not
solvable because the inputs to the
system are novel in other words the
nutrition that the mother has uh is also
novelly good
right and so the baby is likely to be
unusually large compared to what an
ancestral baby would be which means
that's true but that doesn't change day
to day right right right that doesn't
change i'm just saying it you know
yes the process has been overmedicalized
it may be the case where it's become
somewhat medicalized out of necessity
downstream of some kind of novelty like
plenty of food yes um but uh but
but certainly some of the medicalization
was about sort of
i don't know exactly when but let's just
call it sort of early to mid 20th
century
taking agency away from others as if
they were just bystanders passive
bystanders just you know trust them
trust the authorities who aren't
pregnant and not the baby um to you know
bring this baby into the world and you
just happen to have like you know been
the transport or something which is an
insane view
took the agency away from motherhood at
mothers and now we're taking the
motherhood away from mothers by
gender neutralizing
the process because we've gone bat [ __ ]
crazy yes yes i um
i'm not gonna go there today but i did
on twitter this week oh my god it's yeah
now we can talk about differences in um
in how male fetuses and female fetuses
and the placentas so interest like
centers are fascinating actually and i
did not do my research before saying
anything here but there's like at least
four different distinct forms of
placentals among placental mammals
different evolutions it seems like it i
didn't say that because i think i think
i think that we think that
plus
placental mammals euthyrians eu therians
the so-called true mammals as opposed to
like kangaroos
middle mammals as opposed to the mammals
you know the middle mammals as opposed
to the monotremes the echidnas and the
duckbill platypus
um
the placentals which includes basically
everything you can think of except all
the mammals in australia plus possums um
and not also the platypus nakedness um
are the placental mammals the euthyrians
um i think there's something like four
maybe more different
maybe evolutions of placenta and um in
at least one of them i think the
placenta is
maybe entirely maternally derived and at
least in one of them i think it's
entirely fetally derived but in us and
our close relatives and some other group
i don't remember which
it's both
so our placentas are a mixture of
maternal and fetal genes which is just
in and
cells and these things are extraordinary
it will not be obvious to most of our
listeners but
this has profound implications over the
mediation of the conflict between fetus
and mother yeah which
will be will vary quite a bit based on
the mating system of the species in
question so there's a kind of whole
hidden landscape of conflict here yes um
based on because
essentially if
let's say you have a species that mates
for life right if you have a species
that mates for life there's very
little basis for a conflict between the
fetus and the mother over how much
resource to deliver it's not zero but
the offspring has an interest in the
mother remaining uh healthy at the end
of the pregnancy because all future
offspring will be full siblings right
at the point that the baby is effect is
produced inside of a species in which
that is not the expectation then the
point is actually draining the mother of
more resources than it is in her
interest to give up actually makes some
kind of sense and so the placenta's in a
perfect position to
to mediate this
and uh which kind of placenta it is is
going to have an effect over you know
who has the upper hand or is it a
stalemate yeah
very much so so sort of downstream of
david higgs work in the early mid 90s
absolutely
yeah um
i don't know where we were but let's um
i oh i guess the one last thing i was
going to say about um
about this research on obstetricians
um was
assuming that your
your proposition is not right and that
there really is no reason to assume
dependence between mothers in um
in a
obstetrical ward
people tend to
find dependence between events where
there is none you know we we are really
we're pattern seekers and we're really
good at finding pattern where there is
none and you know that that tendency is
what the scientific method is for that's
what statistics is for that's what you
know all these sorts of things to reduce
bias are for uh but absent that we are
we're going to over generalize pattern
and apply it where there apply our
understanding where there wasn't
anything to apply and and be wrong about
it so take that tendency
and um and add like category errors
like
um you know what
like these things that are being used to
immunize people against covid are
vaccines in the same way that the yellow
fever vaccine is a vaccine
we can call them both vaccines but
there's a lot of reason to think that
actually those weren't different words
yes they weren't different words and
what you're pointing to and what we have
pointed to before in terms of basically
the delivery mechanism as a proxy for
something is also very human especially
in light of the fact that all of us
almost all of us
have
some sort of an uneasy relationship with
uh needles
so now
you and i have faced a lot of needles i
think we have much
lower sensitivity to needles than most
people but the point is
every time everyone should be excited
about the prospect of a needle
approaching them
right and
fluid being injected into a tissue where
there's no space for it is it's an
uncomfortable thought you know how does
it expand is it tearing tissue whatever
it does
um so the point is the human being
has a kind of proxy sense of like
okay i'm about to be punctured i'm going
to have some stuff injected and then
it's going to be over and then there's
relief right and the point is actually
almost nothing that matters is that well
i won't say that actually
uh dr john campbell did a very
interesting video which i think should
have been much more widely viewed
it was widely viewed but it should have
been even more widely viewed in which he
discussed
the fact that there was
it used to be that the method of giving
a vaccination involved pulling back on
the plunger to make sure that you hadn't
hit a vein because the idea was not to
inject
the vaccines into the circulatory system
yes right it's supposed to be in the
interstitial fluid
and anyway the way to detect that is to
pull back on the plunger and see if you
get blood and there's a question about
what fraction of adverse events are
actually the result of the fact that the
vaccination vaccination itself
mechanically didn't go the way it was
supposed to and it just didn't get to
the tissue it was supposed to get to it
went to the wrong tissue it went to
every tissue because it got injected
into the circulation right so um anyway
these things matter but uh but putting
that aside
the important thing that happens on the
injection is really about all of the
complex stuff downstream of it it's the
immunological stuff which most people
have a very crude intuition for at best
right the idea of like oh well it
created antibodies okay well what
fraction of the immunity to this
particular disease is based in
antibodies right that's already a
complicated question right right right
right um so
uh
yes the proxy because because there is a
small trauma that comes along with
getting an injection
and it's very finite in time
and it's always the same or pretty close
to it right the actual fact of injection
yeah people have a very narrow model and
the point is the really intriguing stuff
is involved in
what is inside that syringe
right and all of the impacts that it may
have
which is something most people have no
model for right and i guess i mean i
think that's
at first i thought maybe you were making
almost the opposite point that i was
going to arrive at but i think it's the
same really which is that
this tendency to effectively imagine
dependence between events or correlation
between events that isn't there um is
being weaponized against us with regard
to
well
you've gotten the shots before so just
are you pro-shot or anti-shock just do
it right so that's i guess that's
that's that point um
i think it's time to read the cs lewis
essay all right unless you have
something
before that um
no okay
you have not heard this yet i have not
it is uh it was sent
to me yesterday and i happened to be in
front of my email when it came in
therefore i actually saw it unlike
a remarkable number of the emails that
come in that i don't seem to see until
months later if ever
this was published in 1948 by c.s lewis
called on living in an atomic age
in one way we think a great deal too
much of the atomic bomb
how are we to live in an atomic age
i am tempted to reply wise you would
have lived in the 16th century when the
plague visited london almost every year
or as you would have lived in a viking
age when raiders from scandinavia might
land and cut your throat at night or
indeed as you were already living in an
age of cancer an age of syphilis an age
of paralysis an age of air raids an age
of railway accidents and age of motor
accidents
in other words do not let us begin by
exaggerating the novelty of our
situation
believe me dear sir or madam you and all
whom you love were already sentenced to
death before the atomic bomb was
invented
it is perfectly ridiculous to go about
whimpering and drawing long faces
because the scientists have added one
more chance of painful and premature
death to a world which already bristled
with such chances and in which death
itself was not a chance at all but a
certainty
if we are all going to be destroyed by
an atomic bomb
let that bomb when it comes find us
doing sensible and human things praying
working teaching reading listening to
music bathing the children playing
tennis chatting to our friends over a
pint in a game of darts not
huddled together like frightened sheep
and thinking about bombs
they may break our bodies a microbe can
do that but they need not dominate our
minds
what the atomic bomb has really done is
to remind us forcibly of the sort of
world we are living in and which during
the prosperous period before we were
beginning to forget
and this reminder is so far as it goes a
good thing
we have been waked from a petty dream
nope
we've been awake from a pretty dream and
now we can begin to talk about realities
it is our business to live by our own
law not by fears to follow in private or
in public life the law of love and
temperance even when they seem to be
suicidal and not the law of competition
and grab even when they seem to be
necessary to our own survival
for it is part of our spiritual law
never to put survival first not even the
survival of our species
we must resolutely train ourselves to
feel that the survival of man on this
earth much more of our own nation or
culture or class is not worth having
unless it can be had by honorable and
merciful means
nothing is more likely to destroy a
species or a nation than a determination
to survive at all costs
those who care for something else more
than civilization are the only people by
whom civilization is at all likely to be
preserved
those who want heaven must have served
earth best
those who love man less than god do most
for man
let the bomb find you doing well
that is a very challenging essay
yeah um so i'm struck by a number of
things you know one
i do think that part of the issue that
he raises is something i think about a
lot which is
you know your own death is
something you're wired to avoid under
most circumstances
um
but the
extinguishing of your lineage and then
ultimately your species is that thing
magnified yeah
right you ought to be um much more
alarmed at the elimination of
you know your family or your tribe than
you are at the prospect of your own
death and the elimination of your
species is even worse and he
specifically counsels in there
that survival at all costs is not the
right answer
but that raises some questions too right
if one has to compromise their values
to get through a bottleneck so that your
lineage can continue
surely there are some cases in which
that is exactly the right thing to do
and it is not
the destruction of those principles
and then there's another way in which
he's right if your species is going to
be you know
a cancer on the universe by virtue of
you know
being a purely destructive evil
force that cares not that it creates
suffering then maybe the universe is
just better off without it right
um
so anyway i also hear it as a council
against fear and against shutting down
life
because you are fearful of the newest
thing that has arrived
that is at risk of taking you out
yeah i agree with this exactly
and i must say i do a little correction
for myself which is you know i find the
prospect
i don't find my own
death particularly
troubling i find i do
you know i find your death the prospect
of your death very troubling and i find
the predicament that i will leave on my
death troubling but i don't find
the fact of it troubling
but
as you scale up it gets more and more
horrifying
to a point
right if you run the exercise of
all right
the earth is about to be destroyed by
some impossibly
large force about which nothing can be
done is it the photons
something vogon like or you know a large
object
emerging from you know
that's been orbiting the sun at some
very low periodicity or something like
that
right somehow that is
even though as it occurred you would
experience a death that would presumably
i mean unless it was instantaneous be
troubling and painful or whatever else
it would be there's a way in which
it's just sort of easy to accept it
because there's nothing to be done
right
i don't think i feel that way you don't
oh gosh i guess i just found a
defect in my personality but we're
buying or we just disagree i don't see
where there's any reason to assume a
defect
um i mean i'd be curious i actually i
don't know i don't know how
you know how that would split for most
people
or you know and it's not it's not clear
that there's two positions right there
probably a lot of positions but i i
think on first pass hearing that my
reaction to oh
that's not i don't i don't like the idea
of there
not just being no future for me but no
future for anyone right i mean maybe the
difference is
you know i i
there's some part of me that has uh it
needs to just
confront the existential to get rid of
it
right
because ultimately you know it is all
existential i mean
yep
let's let's put it this way there is no
justification for the claim
that being alive is better than being
dead right i am firmly convinced that
holding on to life is a great idea but
of course i would be wouldn't i being
the descendant of you know three and a
half billion years of creatures that
preferred life over death right um but
you know is being organized better than
being disorganized as a crystal
better than a you know a puddle um
right there's just philosophically
nothing to do with it and
similarly
there's no
[Music]
no lineage is getting out of here alive
ultimately
right yeah
in light of that
okay it's just going like
full
and but existential here no but i guess
look first of all there's a kind of my
grandfather used to rail i think against
existentialists right because there was
a kind of um
it was an excuse
for not doing things the fact that it
was all futile right
and so i don't i in general i don't tend
to read the existentialists that way
that's that's more you know that that
hedonism is the excuse existentialism i
agree there's a bifurcation between the
hedonist response to this and another
response and i'm definitely in the other
camp which is yeah let's let's put
everything into doing this as well as
possible even though ultimately
it uh
it will be futile yeah and let's
pray if that's your thing and work and
teach and read and listen to music and
bathe the children and play tennis and
chat to our friends over a pint in a
game of darts right right let us
dear lineage let us leave it all on the
field right yeah
why not what i mean you have this
unbelievably improbable opportunity yeah
so what are you saving it for right so
what are you saving it for yeah you know
what what are we being at what are we
being asked right now
to save it for
as in
most of the countries or people are
listening to us at the moment
we are being told
this just might not end
you might have your activities and your
behaviors and your freedoms restricted
and restricted and restricted it might
just go on indefinitely
what for what
like what right what even
are you imagining that you're
promising us at the end of this
so
you know just go back to what we already
had
which we didn't have to ask for
right why wouldn't why wouldn't we
strive to get it right
and recognize i mean that's the thing is
that any you know he makes the point
very well at any moment that it happens
whenever it is whatever it is that's
coming for you
at the point that it happens the point
is you want to be
worthy of whatever and he labels it as
heaven and uh you and i wouldn't do that
but um but the point is it's a good it's
a good proxy for something you know did
you did you make good use of your
opportunity or not and not everybody has
the same opportunity so you can't judge
everybody by the same standard
right but given what opportunity you you
had
did you make use of it did you do it
well or did you waste it or did or did
you accept
that this moment is so terrifying
and given that what you are being told
is has with it a vague hint of a promise
that isn't even a promise that if you
just do what we tell you to do it will
all get better
you're going to be in stasis for
god knows how long
well and maybe maybe this is the thing
and i think
you know i've been trying to wrestle
this into a form that can be conveyed
right because it's the kind of thing
that either a person already gets it or
it's very hard to get it but the point
is
in objective terms this is a very
terrifying moment right we know lots of
highly intelligent people who are now
gathering people who don't know each
other who are gathering around the idea
that something terrible is a foot that
we don't know exactly what it is and
that
we the trouble is going to get worse
right
that's a paralyzing thought for many
but it can be a liberating thought too
right the point is this is a moment that
is full of
meaning it is full of hazard and in some
sense i think
you know
if it was a wall of fire
right but it was just a wall of fire
then the point is
okay not going into fire that's the
initial instinct but going through the
wall of fire might be the right instinct
right it might be the only one that is
actually defensible if you understood
you know even not knowing how thick it
is just the chance that it's just a wall
of fire and it's not
you know a landscape of fire
uh you know it's it's it's burundia
effectively right if you didn't know
what was beyond the wall of ice
and you didn't have a choice then the
answer is okay
beyond the wall of ice if there is such
a thing
well this is going to muddle it but to
go back to your first invocation of fire
today uh
it doesn't look like a wall of fire to
which some number of people be like okay
i'm i'm suited up i don't know i don't
know if i can make it but i know what i
have to do
and this
this feels more like your room 101 this
feels more like customer service
hellscape like
what
what even is this it's coming from all
sides i'm in it i can't escape i can't
opt out
what do i do but that
that's it and i don't know i don't know
that i can say it
but
you've got
customer service as the alternative to
what might be a wall of fire
customer service will always feel safer
than confronting the wall of fire always
there's no minute in any day when the
wall of fire seems better on the other
hand if you've got a wall of fire and
the idea is well i'm just going to
resort to talking to customer service
right i'll just hang out over here with
my customers
right over here in room 101 with
customer service that is not the
solution to your problem right that is
delaying confronting the problem because
you can't guarantee that there's
anything good that comes from
confronting it on the other hand
yeah you know
we have an opportunity and we are
squandering it
and as much as evolution
sets us to a
game in which its objective is the
persistence of genes into the future
that needn't be our objective right and
i'm going to return to this theme at
some point in the future but
i do wonder
the chinese and i don't mean the chinese
lineage i mean the chinese government
right the governing structure
seems to have figured something out
right it's very effective right it may
have just
conquered an important level of weaponry
that we're going to struggle to catch up
with this hypersonic
stuff among other things right it's
figured out a lot
is it worth it
their system doesn't liberate people
and so the point is
let's say it is stronger
better
less easily better by some objective
standards right better by an objective
standard that we would all agree is good
like yeah getting into the future is
good maybe it's better at getting into
the future right but
who wants to go into the future that's
not the only objective standard by which
we should measure the value of our lives
and in fact what i'm really arguing i
think is
given that objective standard i'll take
a subjective standard i'll take
decent people formulating their own
subjective thing and saying look i'd
rather do something
yes
better
aesthetically better
more compassionate
right and not be so goddamn effective at
getting into the future that we
surrender all the special stuff about
being a human and we're just some kind
of protoplasm that
yes is still around in some distant
location and you know
yeah the next millennium oh that's good
um i think that was
that's both an excellent place to end
and uh and pretty deep and extend the
podcast you're not ending
okay
that's it
i'm out
um
i think maybe people appreciated uh the
brief conversation about sea lions last
week and as it turns out
you saw evidence that someone had been
watching
and no
sorry
that someone had most definitely not
been watching had presumably gotten into
their car
at the coast failed to look at their
check c engine light
no
failed to check their no i can't even
say it failed to look at their check sea
lion light perfect there it is
failed to recognize that why they were
doing this the entire drive inland from
the coast the oregon coast was because
there was in fact sea like paracel ions
on their hood
got to the willamette stopped short as i
advised the sea lions flew off into the
water where you apparently saw them yes
you came home for a walk by the river
and said
saw two sea lions
and i still don't believe you yep no i
was i was standing with a couple of uh
friends of ours we were talking about
um the the predicament that we you know
people find ourselves in you know in the
uh present and all
and uh
yeah i was sort of tracking out of the
corner of my eye something was going on
and it didn't did were they flying at
that point were they being launched no
no they were there was something in the
water i could see the ripples it was a
large thing i
felt it must be a paddle board or
something that i couldn't see somehow oh
great now we look like sea lions to you
some more than others
[Laughter]
[Applause]
but yeah two sea lions
swam past headed up river
um apparently
in the aftermath of absurd this
extraordinary event happening i did look
it up and it turns out that this is i
don't know if it's an annual occurrence
but it's certainly happened before and
apparently they swim up the willamette
which you know we're pretty far inland
um
but they swim yeah i mean they swim with
the colombia presumably to the planet
they don't they don't take a train i
mean unless they happen to be on
someone's hood um but they you know they
don't come over land yeah no they uh
they swim all the way but they i think
they go to the uh the falls in oregon
city oh and they eat steelhead
apparently sturgeon and lamprey
no one misses the lamprey
no not even the lamprey's mothers
um
the sturgeon are fascinating actually i
saw dead sturgeon um flung up on the
rocks over the summer at one point when
i was um
when i was paddle boarding uh turkey
vulture trying to get into it could not
could turkey vulture could not break
into the sturgeon but they're amazing
fish super ancient as our lamprey uh and
then steelhead you saw a particular
sturgeon
i did not like sturgeon general it was
not the sturgeon general no it was not
it was the sturge in particular
um
that steelhead are the anadromous um
non-salmon like what no they're saying
no they're salmon they are they're not
paris
ah they're itero paris
let's let's define our germans oh of
course we're going to have to do so once
let's start with anka rankus you start
you spell it
it starts with an o you go on
so ankarinkus is the genus to which all
the pacific salmon and it's not really
that smart but
to which all the pacific salmon but not
the atlantic salmon belong and then
there are a few other species too which
we call trout including steelhead uh so
you know king salmon coho silver
whatever chum there's one more i can't
think of um
and
we use the word so an uh anadromous and
then in a repairs and semi-paris uh the
pacific salmon are both
semal paris and anadromous paris semel
sem means somehow one and itero is like
iterated means many paris it's like um
mating event or reproductive event uh so
species that are semi-paris mate once
then die species that are iterate paris
mate multiple times um and the pacific
salmon are semi-paris so they do this
famous thing
where they're born in fresh water they
go out to sea and spend their
adult years at sea
and then begin to change their
physiology as they come back to fresh
water and that move from fresh to salt
and back to fresh is the anatomy part
that's anadromousness
and then they come back into their natal
stream
uh to find mates and and then die and
that's the symbol paris part but still
wait a second
so trout are salmonids
they are in the same clade as the
pacific salmon and not they're much more
closely related to pacific than atlantic
salmon right yeah the trout are the
salmonids that are not anadromous and
they are also not
uh some paris except steelhead you say
except steelhead are the exceptions so
steelhead
i think because they are itero paris
that is to say reproduce in multiple
years they go back out to sea and then
come inland commuters
are
they are
described informally as trout but they
are in fact salmon that break the uh the
semel paris rule
um
we can come back another day to
uh my hypothesis for why the pacific
salmon
are semal paris
rather than itaero paris with the
exception of the steelhead in contrast
to the east coast
yeah selma exactly
yeah let's do that if you let's come
back there yeah um yeah let's actually
do that next next week because we're
we're in that part of the year right now
here in the pacific coast um i actually
don't know
um what the mating cycle and everything
of salmo is in the atlantic coast but
pacific
pacific salmon are coming back except
for what is it um
is it silver that are spring breeders
but everyone else is returning to their
natal homes right about now yeah we
should go check it out
yeah
okay right now or no no we got a q a to
do yes
all right uh with that
we just keep on going
we
are going to take a 15 minute break as
we tend to do longer depending on the
tech and then be back with that live q a
you can ask questions at
darkhorsesubmissions.com
www.dockersmissions.com
email any logistical questions but not
questions for us to answer in the q a
to darkhorsemoderator gmail.com
again the
open question asking period is right now
at my patreon through midday tomorrow
pacific time midday sunday october 24th
and then the
monthly private q a will be a week from
tomorrow
and uh
seriously consider reading our book if
you are enjoying the kinds of
conversations we're having here some of
it is directly about the stuff that we
talk about in the book but it's that
provides
the evolutionary toolkit with which to
be able to empower yourself
to
think through claims being made by
officials and authorities and begin to
try to figure out whether or not they're
making evolutionary sense
so
anything else to say no i think we're
there all right
be good to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside be well everyone
[Music]
[Music]
you